good morning Madrid what's up with you
Marcos I don't like seeing this place
empty Martha eight years and twenty
cardboard boxes and 15 plastic ones
you've counted them yeah of course they
when is this thing starting then in a
week a week you're leaving for London
and didn't tell me anything about it
what's up nothing easy that's the
problem nothing's happening in my life
listen you're a great actress and a very
special person
today's our last day in this place so I
really want tonight to be good to all of
our wonderful professions with no future
no what now close your eyes try to relax
let the fairy godmother fulfill all your
wildest dreams who would you take to a
deserted island
hahaha only two people will fit you can
only choose to take one
you're going to tell the truth only the
truthful honest by the Bothan I've had
the absolute best nights with you and
they've been the absence of the worst
good things shouldn't have to change
hate now look you have to accept that
things are going to be different
sometimes for the better
you